a former family vlogger named Ruby Frank
just pled guilty to four felony counts
of second-degree aggravated child abuse
according to video footage of the
hearing that was uploaded to YouTube uh
this I don't follow family vloggers I
don't really follow vloggers of any sort
uh but this is a Utah mother of six and
she has 2.3 million YouTube followers
it's that's a big YouTube channel and
had a a Family Channel called Eight
passengers and I guess what she did was
she would just film her family and all
of her little kids and she's now been
charged with six counts of felony child
abuse and pled guilty to
four uh her her business partner jod
hilderbrand was arrested in August after
cops found one of Frank's children with
open wounds after running away from the
business partner's home another kid was
found malnourished just really terrible
stuff glad that this woman is uh going
to see some just Justice and that the
kids are going to have some
justice at a deeper level
though all family vlogging is child
abuse as far as I'm concerned it's
not you're not always beating the kids
or mal nourishing them but it's all
really bad I'm not I'm not in any way
surprised by this story when I see
people exploiting their kids for content
on the internet I
think bad
parenting stop it immediately
don't do it even people who aren't
making money on it even people who who
are just farming likes who just get a A
Rush of excitement when they see people
liking their pictures and then they they
exploit their children to get all these
likes don't do
it your job as a parent is to protect
your children and part of protecting
your children means not uploading 10,000
pictures of them to the internet where a
bunch of who knows who are going to look
at them are going to watch them it's
going to expose them to some degree of
no notoriety and fame it might it might
make them look foolish it might it might
you might be uh deriving your clicks out
of mocking them or or exploiting your
anxieties and your your frustration with
your children and it's just bad what
good can possibly come of that it is a
problem that we've been talking about
for weeks now in all sorts of different
areas we were talking about surrogacy a
couple of weeks ago about how the
problem with surrogacy is is that it
commoditized human beings we shouldn't
treat human beings as means to an end we
shouldn't treat human beings as objects
for our enjoyment or our benefit we
should treat human beings as ends in
themselves not to be commoditized not to
be turned into uh vessels for rent not
to be turned into products to be
purchased like you see in the case of
ibf and surrogacy not to be turned into
media objects to exploit for clicks or
likes or money it's just wrong these are
your
kids don't do it it's bad
that the difference between this woman
who just pled guilty to Mal nourishing
and beating her kids or whatever the
charges were four felony counts the
difference between her and every other
family vlogger blogger posting a million
pictures of your kids for all the world
to see is a is a difference of degree it
is not a difference in kind so if you're
doing it cut it out okay that is some
really golden advice that I am giving
you right now and when you want actual
physical gold you got to check out Birch
gold right now text Nolls to 9898 98
this Christmas season you can diversify
your savings into physical precious
medals while stockpiling free silver in
your home safe do not miss out on Birch
gold group's most popular special of the
year now through December 22nd for every
$5,000 you spend with Birch gold they
will send you a 1 o Silver Eagle Coin
for free text nolles kwes to 98.9 8.98
to claim your eligibility now you can
purchase gold and silver and have it
shipped directly to your home or have
Birch Gold's precious metal Specialists
help you convert an existing Ira 401K
into a tax sheltered Ira in gold for no
money out of pocket and they will send
you free silver for every five grand you
purchase keep it for yourself or give
something with real value as a stocking
stuffer this year that's a very good
stocking stuffer just text keyword
nolles to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility with an plus rating with a
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers now is the best time to
buy gold from Birch gold text nolles kW
to 98 9898 claim your eligibility for
free silver un qualifying purchases
before December 22nd that is nolles kwes
to 98 998
98 speaking of
Courts you know Sandra de o Conor died
do you know this this was I I guess
while I was away when I was pursuing my
dream of becoming a professional sitar
player in India if only I had brought my
sitar it would have worked out I think
it was while I was away maybe it was
right before I left but in any case no
one has talked about it you remember
when Ruth b Ginsburg died and it was all
we heard about for months well we we
heard about it before she died everyone
was waiting for her to die preparing all
of the eulogies and the parades and the
biopics and the
everything and then she died and then it
was another two months of mour and then
Sandra Deo Conor dies no one even thinks
about most people don't even know who
she
is everyone remembers Ruth Bader
Ginsburg you know the first woman on the
Supreme Court but no one remembers
Sandra de o Conor the actual first woman
on the Supreme Court the way that
history has been revised and the way
that the narrative has been formed it is
as though Ruth Bader Ginsburg the
Trailblazer the woman who paved a path
for all of us but especially for women
it is as though she were the first woman
on the Supreme Court appointed by Bill
Clinton and that wonderful liberal
president but that's now what happened
the first woman on the court was Sandra
de o Conor who was at least vaguely
conservative Who was appointed by Ronald
Reagan but that doesn't work with the
narrative it doesn't fit I'm not even
the biggest fan of Sandra de o Conor's
Juris Prudence but it seems rather
unfair that she's written out of history
but of course of course she was going to
be written out of the
story the story is already written
okay conservatives are evil Liberals are
good conservatives are oppressing the
masses Liberals are liberating
people that is why when a conservative
wins an election something had to be
wrong with the election even if it was
the cleanest election ever in history
something had to be wrong the the people
were hypnotized into a false
consciousness the fraud happened at the
level of the of the Soul
actually the the the the deception that
was perpetrated by the conservatives was
so subtle no one even saw it
happening but it had to be wrong the
Liberals have to win the
elections popularly because they are the
ones liberating people and so if the
people don't know their own good it's
because of the conservatives tricked
them has to be the case Donald Trump had
to lead an Insurrection never mind that
he told people don't don't go into the
capital go home be peaceful don't be
violent don't be nice he had to do it
the horn hat guy had to be an evil
insurrectionist on the brink of aeta
about to shred the Constitution it
doesn't matter that the video footage
showed that he was getting a private
tour around the capital by the police
doesn't matter that the only person
killed in political violence on January
6th was a trump supporter killed by a
trigger happppy cop none of that
matters the the story was already
written okay and any facts that don't
fit that narrative are going to be
twisted they're going to be Rewritten or
they're going to be discarded and in the
case of Sandra de o Conor she doesn't
fit the narrative that the first woman
on the court would be appointed by a
Conservative Republican that she herself
would be at least somewhat conservative
that she would not stand up for all the
big liberal causes it doesn't fit so
she's gone she's out and the replacement
is Ruth b Ginsburg and that's that the
reason I mention all of this is not just
to gripe or to defend the sacred honor
of Sandra de o'conor or something it's
to remind conservatives we will never
get the credit it's not going to happen
we're never going to get the nice New
York Times piece we're never going to
get the the beautiful PBS special we're
never going it's not going to happen
we're always going to be evil we're
always going to be idiots we're always
going to be knuckle dragging hitlerian
figures who want to destroy our country
and kill everyone on Earth it's that's
always going to be the case in fact if
the libs are giving you the nice New
York Times article they are giving you
the PBS special they are giving you the
big parades then you're probably doing
something wrong if you are receiving the
plots and the honors of this world and
the principalities and powers and
spiritual wickedness and high places
that govern this world you're probably
doing something wrong that should worry
you that should worry you a hell of a
lot more than being discarded or being
lied about or being slandered or being
libeled okay it's a great honor that no
one is paying attention to Sandra de o
Conor's
death it is something that ought to
ought to be worrisome to the friends and
admirers of Ruth Bader Ginsburg that she
is so so highly revered by a a rotten
very very corrupt political structure
that's the way it goes there is no
there's no neutrality here okay and as
far as the minations of this world go
the libs have the upper hand no doubt
about it man what a great clip that was
huh that was good now hey oh ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time